Wenn ich Podcast-Dufo höre, bin ich andächtig und still.
Florentin will ich, ich hängere deinen Lippen und liebe deine Witze, Stefan. Das ist wahr, ja das ist richtig. Tietze und Will ergibt zusammen als zusammengezogenes Wort Witze. Ja, ich glaube, im Alter von acht Jahren ist mir das das erste Mal aufgefallen und seitdem lässt mich das nicht mehr los. Ja, das stimmt. Mich lässt es auch nicht mehr los. Das ist unglaublich. Es trammert sich an mir, an mein Hirn. Aber wem ist es auch aufgefallen, natürlich, Tobias, Max und Svenja, die sich hier zu dritt zusammengetan haben. Man hat zwei Singen hören. Einen Gitarre spielen hören. Dritte Person, na ach so, ich habe mir den Singer-Songwriter-mässig mit Gitarre in der Hand vorgestellt, den Sänger. Also eine Person ist hier entweder im Hintergrund oder nicht vokal vertreten. Trotzdem vielen, vielen Dank. Wie gross war der Raum? Kannst du schätzen, wie gross der Raum war, in dem das aufgenommen wurde? Es gab bei solchen, ja, Kathedralen gross. Also man muss ja auch mal sagen, es gibt ja bei solchen Aktionen immer den einen Freund, der dann dabei ist, aber nicht wirklich was beisteuern kann, weil er weder Gitarre spielt noch singt, noch weissentlich Aufnahmprogramme beherrscht oder Mikrofone hat. Aber er ist halt nun mal dabei, weil soll man den ausladen dann dafür? Nein. Ich glaube, es sind zwei von denen waren motiviert und auch Podcast-UFO-Hörer und Hörerinnen. Der andere ist eher der Musiker und die haben sich an den gewendet und haben gesagt, ey Max, hast du nicht Lust, Gitarre zu spielen? Und der will natürlich Musiker sein, nimmt jeden Gig, also kann sich vielleicht jetzt auch nicht leisten, einen Gig auszuschlagen. So wie jeden Gag nehmen. Hat aber inhaltlich keine Ahnung, worum es überhaupt gibt, was Titze ist und was das ist, aber man singt das so weg. Und dann gibt es diesen einen Kumpel, der gar keine Ahnung hat von Musik, der weiß auch nicht, was da passiert, und er sagt dann sowas wie, können wir das nochmal machen? Ja. Warum? Ja, weil, kannst du noch mehr Akkorde spielen, vielleicht? Ein paar mehr, einfach noch mal mehr Akkorde.
Hau noch Zestur rein. Okay, sagen wir ein Akkord mehr. Man denkt so, ja, okay, so funktioniert Musik nicht. Doch, vertrau mir, ich habe da ein Gefühl für, so Rick Rubin-mässig, der ja auch keine Ahnung von Musik hat, aber halt weiss, wie es die richtigen Fragen stellt. Ja, aber ich denke mir das auch so bei so Sängern von so dem Poker-Rap zum Beispiel. Knofen Satrogaria, der Kapador. Der Typ geht abends zu Hause und denkt sich, was mache ich eigentlich? So der hat keine Ahnung, was Pokémon sind. Er hat doch Songs für Eminem geschrieben. Ja? Nein. Ach so, ich dachte, du kennst ihn persönlich. Nein, er hat keine, nein, der Pokerrap-Typ hat keine Songs für Eminem geschrieben. So, ich weiss nicht, die Musikindustrie, der sieht ja oft mit seinen grossen vertrauenden Augen und sagt, ja, erzähl mir mehr, erzähl mir mehr, Vater.
Du, Stefan, du bist so ein Socializer, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du auf einer Party bist und dann so, ah, was machst du?
Ja, ich mache einen Podcast und du, ja, ich habe damals den Poker-Rap gerappt und es so, okay, krass, der Typ und der geht auch abends zu Hause und denkt sich, Digiflor, Biso, Knast, was mache ich eigentlich, wer bin ich eigentlich und fährt er über so eine hohe Brücke, nachts, ganz alleine und dann hält er mal an, er steigt mal aus dem Auto aus, er stellt sich ans Geländer, stopp, stopp stop, stop! Ich habe gerade den Poker-Rap aufgenommen. Sie waren der für den Poker-Rap? Ja. Krass, was haben Sie seitdem gemacht? Ich habe jeden Tag wache ich auf und habe diese Wörter im Kopf. Horn-Liu, Gigaflor, Bisa-Knosp, ich weiß nicht was, das ist wie eine fremde Sprache, das ist wie ein Parasit, der sich einfrisst in mein Herz und jeden Tag sich durch meinen ganzen Körper pocht mit diesem Nonsens. Ich kann keinen klaren Gedanken mehr fassen. Sie sind ja kein Pokémon-Fan. Na, mich interessiert das nicht, ich weiss nicht mal, was ein Pokémon ist. Snobilica, Ditto, Geowatz, Hornlio, den ganzen Tag. Ich habe diese Stimmen im Kopf, diese diese wesen diese kreaturen sie leben unter
meiner hau aber wie sind sie dann damals auf die idee gekommen ich habe den gig angenommen meine agentin meinte ich soll das machen das war 2000 euro für so ein album das mache ich natürlich klar will ich mit meiner eigenen band erfolgreich sein aber bis dahin muss man natürlich auch mal sowas annehmen aber wofür stehen sie denn im leben was wollen sie denn für nichts ich mache alles für geld für nichts, ich mache alles für Geld. Und jetzt habe ich diese Wesen im Kopf. Rosanna! Aber Sie sind doch mehr als Rosanna und Bisa Knoss. Das dachte ich auch, aber bis heute habe ich sie im Kopf. Sie leben in mir, Ultrigaria, Knuffenza, was sind das denn für Worte? Aber sagen Sie doch was über sich. Machen Sie Kunst über sich. Ich weiss nicht mehr, wie ich heisse. Was macht Ihnen Angst? Ich weiss es nicht mehr. wenn jemand sagt wie wie heisst du dann sage ich ich bin lumando ich kenne mich doch nicht aus ich weiss ich habe nur dieses diesen quatsch im kopf und dann sprang er ja und ich glaube so geht es max auch bei dem triumvirat max svenja tobias da muss ein schmissigerer name her also Also entweder er macht den anderen meinen Kanterreit, ich kenne eure Nachnamen nicht, aber ich kenne sie schon, aber ich werde sie nicht nennen. Ich werde euch jetzt nicht doxen hier, ich kenne euren Namen, eure Adressen. Doxen mag ich sehr als Ausdruck, was ich jetzt neu gelernt habe, ist Raw Dogging. Kennst du Raw Dogging? Es ist schon ein sehr lange Podcast-Ufo-Thema gewesen, hat jetzt den Titel erst bekommen. Wir waren damals zu langsam, haben keinen Titel dafür uns ausgedacht. Raw Dogging ist jetzt gerade, glaube ich, primär beim Fliegen, Langstreckenflüge und wirklich keine Unterhaltung mitzunehmen, in Anspruch zu nehmen, keine Musik zu hören, Sogar, und jetzt wird es dann auch gesundheitsschädlich, nichts zu essen, nichts zu trinken, ich besuchte es in einem Satz, ich habe den Flug gerowdockt.
Aber sind wir hier nicht relativ nah an einer fast schon religiösen Enthaltsamkeit, zu sagen, wie wirklich der Mönch, der ohne Gelüste, ohne Bedürfnisse, ohne Eigentum einfach nur mit sich selbst und Gott unterwegs ist. Ja, auf eine Art schweigt ja auch, also dieses Schweigekloster, dieses in sich höhere. Das ganze religiöse Kram kommt zurück über andere Namen. Das scheint schon ein Bedürfnis des Menschen zu sein, dass du fast eremitenhaft da in deiner Hütte sitzt und dann einfach nichts macht oder das ist ja. Ich finde es aber wahnsinnig egoistisch und scheisse, weil ihr tut dann immer so, als diese Leute, die das machen, euch meine ich jetzt, es tut dann immer so, als wäre das so eine Raw Dogger, genau Raw Dogger, so eine krasse Leistung und ihr habt irgendwie euren Schweinehund überwunden und ihr seid die Alphas da draussen und krass und Mental Health und Stärke und es ist nur eine Frage des Mindsets. Aber ihr bringt nicht die Leistung. Ich finde, die, die neben euch sitzen, die tun mir leid. Die das aushalten müssen, dass wir die ganze Zeit nicht unterhalten, oder? Man darf ja nichts machen. Das finde ich ja gut. Aber es ist ja eigentlich eine Gegenbewegung zur Hyperaktivität, TikTok ständig in die Hand nehmen und jetzt sagt man, okay, man geht komplett auf die andere Seite. Genau, Raw Dogging. Und ich finde allein die Vorstellung wahnsinnig irritierend und so angstentflössend. Und wir haben uns mal lange über Leute in der Bahn unterhalten. Da habe ich den Begriff jetzt noch nicht aufgeschnappt, ich glaube, aber ganz einfach übertragen. Und da war halt eine ältere Frau hinter mir und ältere Menschen machen das häufig. Ältere Menschen raw doggen schon seit 1872. Raw doggen durch ihr Leben und meine Mom würde das genauso machen. Meine Mom fährt nicht oft Zug, aber sie würde es raw doggen. Dann sage ich immer, nimm doch irgendwie Musik mit oder sowas, aber für sie ist das genug Einfluss. Wenn man nicht so oft Bahn fährt, kann ich mir auch vorstellen, da fehlt uns vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Empathie oder das Vorstellungsvermögen, wenn man nicht oft Bahn fährt, man kriegt schon sehr, sehr viele Einflüsse. Ja. Wenn man das aber oft macht, klar, dann irgendwann wird es langweilig und wir sind ja auch so dauerbeschallt, das wäre irgendwie wirklich Abstinenz, aber so. Ich finde, für mich ist es einfach nur eine Unfähigkeit zu planen. Auch irgendwie, wenn man so einen roadtrip macht oder so und dann so sechs stunden auto fährt und ich sitze am steuer und neben mir die person einfach so du weißt doch dass wir lange unterwegs sind und dann verboten also nimm die kopfhörer mit dem buch oder ein podcast oder zumindest so ein schlafkissen und lichen aber. Aber das meine ich. Du kannst ja nicht, wie geht man durch die Welt? Aber der Raw-Dogger ist ja, der aktiv das macht. Das ist ja nicht nur eine verschlafene Planung oder ein Desinteresse, sondern der sagt, okay, ich könnte jetzt meinen Gameboy mitnehmen auf den Flug oder meine Switch, aber ich mache es explizit nicht und nehme das wieder als Leistung mit rein. Das ist, glaube ich, was anderes. Aber ich finde es erstmal interessant, aber ich habe auch Respekt, weil ich glaube, ich könnte das nicht durchziehen. Ja, ich habe auch Respekt. Ich muss nur sagen, die Ecke, aus der es kommt, gefällt mir nicht. Was ist das für eine Ecke? Mindset-Alpha-Ecke, diese Alpha-Mann, wir überwinden uns, wir sind stärker als unser Körper, überwinde deinen Geist. Wie kaputt ist denn der Männlichkeitsbegriff, dass wir da angekommen sind, zu sagen, echte Männer machen nichts, echte Männer sind enthaltsam und machen einfach nichts. Also wie viele Kreise hat dieser Männlichkeitsbegriff gedreht, dass wir da ankommen? Ja, ja, sehr viele Kreise irgendwie. Der Männlichkeitsbegriff muss man sich vorstellen wie so jemand, der in so einer italienischen Stadt, wo der Handyempfang nicht so gut ist, Google Maps anmacht. Und Google Maps weiss nicht, wo Norden ist. Und dann dreht man sich erst mal dreimal im Kreis und dann geht man in eine Gasse und dann, na gut, das war genau die falsche Richtung, dann geht man zurück. Umdrehen. Und das ist der Männlichkeitsbegriff. Ich stelle mir den Männlichkeitsbegriff vor, wie wenn du eine Münze so auf die Seite stellst und dann so rollen lässt.
So eine Weile lang rollst. und das ist der Männlichkeitsbegriff. Ich stelle mir den Männlichkeitsbegriff vor, wie wenn du eine Münze so auf die Seite stellst
und dann so rollen lässt.
So eine Weile lang rollst du gerade,
aber dann nimmst du ganz grosse Kurven
und du kannst im Leben nicht vorhersagen, wo es endet.
Wie in diesen Freizeitpackdingern, wo es so langsam in so ein Loch geht.
Ja, sondern es ist auf eigener Faust und irgendwann dann so blip, blip, blip, blip,
und wir sind gerade in diesem blip, blip, blip, blip, ganz am Ende-Modus, wo es so schlagartig hin und her oszilliert und irgendwann wird es stehen bleiben und dann ist der Begriff tot. Tot oder gefunden? Verschwunden. Gefunden, dann verschwunden. Ich glaube, ich kriege bald auf die Fresse, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, da liegen Schläge in der Luft, denn ich wurde jetzt schon ein paar Mal tatsächlich angepöbelt im Strassenverkehr. Nein. Und da habe ich auch ein interessantes Männlichkeitsexemplar,
ein männliches
Exemplar gesehen, denn
ich werde mittlerweile wirklich zum
pedantischen Radfahrer,
militanter Radfahrer, muss ich sagen,
weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr und
mein normaler Weg, mein Radweg
führt an einem Kreisverkehr durch
und ich kann es nicht ausstehen, wenn Autofahrer
beim Ausfahren aus dem Kreisverkehr nicht blinken. Das ist so nervig und respektlos. Und ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, den Autofahrer nicht verstehen. Für den Autofahrer ist stehenbleiben und weiterfahren überhaupt kein Problem. Ich bremse ab, ich drücke auf das Gasbill und fahre weiter. Für den Radfahrer, der mit Schwung, Radfahrer ist ja ein Schwunggefährt, mit Schwung ankommt und dann komplett auf null bremst und dann wieder losfahren muss, ist ein Riesen-Act. Das heißt, ich will den Schwung immer mitnehmen. Und wenn jetzt jemand im Kreisverkehr ankommt und ich weiss nicht, will der ausfahren oder nicht, muss ich stehen bleiben und dann fährt er aus und dann denke ich mir, hätte es so geblinkt, Energie ist weg, mein Tag ist ruiniert, ich bin eh schon verschwitzt, ist eh schon super nervig, meine Kopfhörer, Schweiss, überall, alles super nervig.
Und die zwei Sekunden Zeitverlust, oh das scheiße.
Und jetzt muss ich wieder zu Kraftverlust, so.
Und dann habe ich ja schon mal gesagt, mache ich ja immer mein Zeichen, um den Leuten zu zeigen, dass sie blinken sollen.
Und ich mache so.
Ja, wäre auch mein Blinkerzeichen.
Und ich weiß immer noch nicht, ob das überhaupt ankommt.
Also ich öffne die Hand wie so eine Qualle, die Hand so wie so ein Weg.
Genau, finde ich ein gutes Bild, eine fortbewegende Qualle.
Es gibt auch so dieses Quassel-Lava, Lava nicht, so, sondern ich mache so diesen Stern, dieses Blinken. Aber es ist halt, man muss sagen, es hat was so Kleinkind-Babyhaftes, also diese, ist ja was Süsses, diese Geste ist süss, weisst du, was ich meine? Es ist nicht wie der Finger oder es ist nicht wie dieser erhobene Zeigefinger oder so eine italienische Hand. Ja, der Vulkan. Ja, da ist so Emotion drin. Das ist halt so eine kindliche Sonnengeste. Ein bisschen schon, ja. Und stell dich mir dich vor, mit einem hochroten Kopf, wahnsinnig wütend. Grosse, grosse Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer auf. Du hast ein grosses, dein grosses Gesicht ist ganz klein, so alles ist so ganz klein in einem kleinen, also leer. Das Gesicht ist leer, ist in der Mitte, ist so zusammengezogen zu so einem kleinen wütenden so Organhaufen in der Mitte. Richtig. Ja, dann diese Geste zu machen, diese Patschehändchen, ist halt auch ein lustiges Bild vielleicht. Ja, absolut, kann ich auch verstehen. Und ich glaube, es kommt auch nicht an. Rufst du denn auch? Nein, ich rufe nichts, es würde nichts bringen. Die Leute, die meisten Griechens sehen es nicht. Klopfst du so gegen diese Scheibe? Sie fahren ja gegen mich, es ist furchtbar. Und letztens war auch die Situation, ich fahre hinten, steht ein Auto an der Kreuzung, ich fahre von hinten und ich weiss nicht, will das Auto abbiegen oder nicht oder kann ich an dem vorbeifahren und dann fahre ich ran und im letzten Moment biegt es dann noch ab, fährt mich fast um und dann habe ich auch das gemacht. So, dieses Zeichen, blink doch, dann hätte ich gesehen, dass du abbiegen willst und das Auto hupt. Was? Das Auto hupt und bleibt stehen. Nein!
Unangenehm, unangenehm. Und ich denke mir ... Weil die sitzen in ihren Metallkäfigen und du bist da exposed auf diesem Drahtesel.
Richtig. Hab ihr schon nicht das beste Gleichgewichtssinn? Nein. Und hupt und bleibt stehen. Ich bleib auch stehen.
Oh mein Gott, ich hasse so.. Weil ich denk mir, bring it.
Nee, für mich, Straßenverkehr ist für mich Planspiel. Planspiel wütend, Planspiel Aggressionsaustausch, Planspiel Prügelei.
Okay, aber es ist im Kopf. Aber sobald es konkret wird, die Leute bleiben stehen, allein schon Scheiben werden runtergemacht, da finde ich, mir läuft sofort, jegliche Emotion weicht aus mir und denkt mir, ich bin doch nicht so sehr invested, wie ich gerade noch dachte. Bei mir ist es ähnlich, aber ich habe tatsächlich oft das Bedürfnis, mit Leuten zu reden, weil ich würde gerne Dinge einfach klären, weil zum Beispiel auch im Internet Kommentare, YouTube-Kommentare, Sachen kritisieren, Sachen und mich nervt, wie das formuliert ist. Und dann geht es ewig immer nicht her, du schreibst einen Kommentar, dann dauert es zwei Tage, schreib dir einen Kommentar. Und ich denke mir immer, ey, schreib deine Handy-Nummer hin, ich rufe dich an, wir klären das in zehn Minuten, ich sage dir, was mein Problem mit deinem Kommentar ist, du erklärst mir, wie es gemeint war, wir finden uns wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Mitte, wir denken, ah, okay, na, glaube ich, glaube schon, meistens so. Und dann lege ich auf und dann ist das Thema auch beendet. Und deswegen habe ich oft oft so dieses auch an der Supermarktkasse und so gedöhnt. Ich würde gerne mit den Leuten kurz reden, das klären und ich glaube, dann findet man schon. Und deswegen war ich ganz glücklich, dass diese Person anscheinend bereit war, mit mir ein Gespräch zu führen. So, Hupen stehen bleiben, ich bleibe auch stehen, ich habe ein bisschen Vorsprung. Du bist wie so ein Alien, was so idealistisch auf die Welt kommt und dann so meint, ich kann hier für Frieden und Ordnung und Sicherheit sorgen, ich rede nur mit den Leuten, dann kriegen wir das schon hin. Genau, ja. Und du bist sofort erschossen, bei der ersten Interaktion. Ja, exakt, genau. Und so ist es ein bisschen auch gekommen, denn das Auto rollt von hinten an und jetzt rede ich ja mit dem Beifahrer. Jetzt rede ich ja mit dem beifahrer weil es links von mir steht ich bin an der rechten seite beifahrer aggressiver aufgepumpter macho mann sagen wir es einfach mal so und kommt mit ihr so was willst du so kommt direkt so am fahrersitz seine freundin am fahrersitz am fahrersitz gefahren aber jetzt habe ich schon so jetzt, der Männlichkeitsberief hat sie ja jetzt schon drei Minuten um die eigene Achse gedreht.
Absolut, das heisst, ich krieg jetzt so, sagst du meine Freundin, kann ich Auto fahren oder was, willst du auf die Fresse? Wahnsinn! So, jetzt denke ich mir schon, wow, also jetzt, okay, wo sind wir denn jetzt angekommen? Ja, ja, ja. Aber spannend eigentlich.
Der Macho-Klischee-Alphamann, der das ja auch sein will und propagiert, von dem man ja jetzt aus unserer Perspektive ausgeht, dass er den altmodischen Begriff von Frauen können nicht fahren mitgeprägt, wenn nicht sogar erfunden hat. Er muss natürlich auch die Ehre seiner Freundin verteidigen. Aber er sitzt auf dem Beifahrersitz, muss die Ehre seiner Freundin verteidigen. So, und das war dann schon eine komische Situation. Ich dachte, wir könnten hier schön die Ebenen auseinanderdröseln, wenn du noch Zeit hast. Wir setzen uns gerne zusammen. Und ich habe nur gesagt, ja, wenn sie blinken, können die Leute auch sehen, wo sie hinfahren wollen. Ja, gesiezt. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich diese sachliche Kritik angebracht habe, wurde aus dem Rollen ein Gas geben und es ist sofort weitergefahren. Das heisst, anscheinend wurde gar nicht, meine Geste wurde gar nicht als sachliche Kritik am Autofahren verstanden, sondern als, was machst du, was ist da los, sondern einfach als vulgäre Geste.
Na, auf die Finger klopfen.
Wahrscheinlich, und als ich dann gesagt habe, ja, Entschuldigung, wenn sie blinken, dann würden wir auch sehen, was sie vorhaben, und dann hat die Freundin direkt aufs Gas getreten und ist vorbeigefahren. Ich habe mir noch einen wütenden Blick des Beifahrers eingefangen, aber das war es dann. Aber da lagen schon Schläge in der Luft. Aber ich persönlich hatte noch nie Kontakt mit Gewalt irgendeiner Form. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, und deswegen habe ich vielleicht auch zu wenig Angst und Respekt, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass ein erwachsener mensch aus seinem auto aussteigt sich aufrichtet und
jemanden der auf dem fahrrad sitzt ins gesicht schlägt ich kann mir das einfach für mich ist
das zu albern ja du hast ja nie aufs maul bekommen das so zu sein absolut und sobald das einmal
passiert verhalte ich mich anders aber bis dahin ist die Vorstellung so lustig, dass jemand von seinem niedrigen Autositz nach oben guckt und sagt, jetzt ist der Moment gekommen, du kritisierst meine Freundin, jetzt haue ich dir aufs Maul, ich gurte mich ab, ich löse den Sicherheitsgurt, ich öffne das Auto, ich steige aus, Zentralverregelung, wirkt umschriftet. Ich richte mich auf, gehe auf diesen, also wirklich null Verteidigung auf dem Drahtesel, gerade so balancierend auf Zehenspitzen stehend. Ich habe den Sattel oft recht hoch. Der Helmallmann, der dann da steht und sagt, ne Entschuldigung, wenn Sie blinken könnten, dann haut man dem auf die Fresse. Ich kann mir das auch nicht vorstellen. Genau, ohne Gegenwehr, weil ich denke mir immer so, also in meinem Kopf baut eine Schlägerei immer so eine Eskalation aus. So, komm her, komm her, komm her und man schubst sich und so. Aber wenn jemand so gar nicht mitmacht und nur sagt so, ich wollte sie nur darauf hinweisen, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen. Die Aggression kam von dir mit dieser aggressiven Vulgärgeste. Aber dient auch als Verteidigungsgeste, falls der Fausthieb kommt, kann ich ihn direkt auffangen mit meiner Blinkelgeste. Die Vorstellung, dass du diesen Airbag-Helm dann um hast, diesen Schal, er dir auf die Fresse haut, kurz davor, aber dieser Helm noch auslöst, du davon geschockt, er davon geschockt, zurückgeworfen wird, noch saurer wird, du so wie so ein Käfer auf dem Rücken, liegst mit diesem Airbag um dich herum, aussieht wie so ein Michelin-Männchen.
Das ist alles, was ich sehen will.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Aber deswegen habe ich da auch jetzt nicht keine Angst, ich hatte schon Respekt, aber ich kann mir das einfach nicht vorstellen. Ja, spannend. Das ist wirklich passiert. Also ich würde mir auch immer denken, wenn jemand so eine klassische Abziehsituation, keine Ahnung, jemand hat ein Messer und sagt ja Geld her. Und ich denk mir, du willst mich wirklich mit einem Messer stechen, schwere Körperverletzungen für meine 50 Euro? Also ernsthaft, das ist dein Plan? Ich denke mir so, dass, also ich habe, also in der Situation hätte ich wahrscheinlich so viel Angst, dass ich machen würde, aber ich denke mir so, das wird nicht passieren, das wird einfach nicht passieren. Ich denke immer, man kann den Bluff callen. Aber hier hätte ich fast aufs Maul bekommen und ich glaube, das wird bald passieren, weil mittlerweile mich nervt das sehr mit diesem Geblinke und es ist wirklich manchmal so, dass ich Autos hinterherfahre und nebenbei fahre und sage, Entschuldigung, sie hat mich fast umgefahren und ich weiß, aber es nervt mich einfach zu sehr, weil ich finde, es gibt Machtgefälle zwischen den Panzerautofahrern und ihr merkt, ich bin wirklich militanter Fahrradfahrer mittlerweile, weil ich finde, du hast auch einfach, wenn du in deinem riesigen Auto sitzt und alles umwalzen kannst und ich in meinem Fahrrad, wo ich bei normaler Fahrt schon Angst um mein Leben habe, da denke ich mir so, nee, da muss man sich irgendwie schon verteidigen ein bisschen. Also ich bin genauso, wenn ich im Auto bin, bin ich natürlich Team Auto. Ja, absolut. Ich fahre ja auch Auto und wirklich vulgär. Ich bin primär, ich bin Militant, genau, ein vulgär Militant. Richtig, ich bin in dem Team, in dem ich gerade bin. Natürlich. Und da bin ich hundertprozentig. Ich bin hundertprozentig kämpfig für das Team, in dem ich bin. Richtig. Und wenn ich so einen Roller fahre, so einen Emmy, so ein Moped, bin ich Team Moped. Ja, absolut. Also da komme ich alle anderen mal. Du bist relativ alleine, aber du bist Team Moped. Team Moped. Und ich bin auch sehr militant, ich hab da wirklich so eine, ich nenne es mal so italienische Diskussionsfreude, also wirklich so laut wird diskutiert, so das können sie nicht machen, wo war sie das denn? Und so bin ich auch wirklich mal. Also auf deutsch, aber mit einem italienischen Melodie-Ansatz. Naja, genau, also ich will jetzt nicht, die habe ich jetzt gerade bewusst nachgemacht, dass er diese italienische Behemenz, genau. Hey, das könnt ihr nicht machen, bitte, äh, wofür ihr das Vorfahren, ich habe keine Vorfahrt, ihr habt keine Vorfahrt. Ja genau, wenn man das nicht hervoran hält, dann machen Regeln keinen Sinn! Und da bin ich mal wirklich diskutierend.
Die ganze, du kennst die Fenloher-Strasse, Stadtkern, Köln, bis zu mir nach Hause, Ehrenfeld, bin ich, habe ich diskutiert mit einer Autofahrerin. Nur, und ich war mir sicher, ich hatte Recht, sie hat mir die Vorfahrt genommen. Jetzt ist das aber leider eine Strasse, wo sehr viel experimentiert wurde mit so Verkehrsexperimenten. Wendloer ist ja ein laufendes Experiment, muss man sagen. Inzwischen ist es eine Einbahnstrasse, aber da, zu der Zeit wurde dann, an dem Tag wurden die Regeln geändert und alle Strassen, alle Seitenstrassen wurden zu Vorfahrtsstrassen gemacht. Und die Fendloer Strasse wurde quasi zu einer Rechts-vor-Links-Strasse. Ach, okay. Das war für mich als Fahrradfahrer, der jeden Tag langfährt, natürlich mega merkwürdig. Am nächsten Tag habe ich gemerkt, ich war falsch, ich war auf der falschen Seite. Aber um einen Tag nur. Ja, aber das ist egal. Das zählt nicht. Das ist ja bitter. Und dann habe ich die ganze und alle haben das ja mitbekommen, wie ich da rumdiskutiere und sage, ja, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe Vorfahrt, ich habe da muss man, ich weiss noch nicht wieder, war ich falsch, habe ich das Schild nicht gesehen.
Ich glaube, ich bin auch oft falsch, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, aber es ist in dem Moment einfach man...
Road Rage, Road Rage is a thing.
Es ist so schwer, weil die Kommunikationssituation so stark behindert ist, hätte man die Möglichkeit, ich hätte immer gerne so eine Art, wie in der Matrix, wenn du dann in so einem weissen Raum bist, wo dann so zwei Stühle kommen, wo man kurz mal Real-Life-Pause drücken kann und sagt, lass uns kurz mal in den Diskussionsraum gehen. Und beide sind nackt. Beide sind nackt, ja. Beide aller ihrer sozialen Status beraubt, keine Kleidung, keine Ämter, nichts, man ist nur noch Mensch. So, und jetzt beginnt nämlich ein anderer Männlichkeitsbegriff, weil ich habe neulich inspiriert aus einem anderen Podcast, die sogenannte Gedenbad, den wir immer gerne referenzieren. Also Hassliebe, Schwingen, Korrekturwille und Pädaterie. Und die haben über die Dokumentation Gym Boys, wenn junge Männer pumpen, in der ARD-Mediathek gesprochen. Die habe ich daraufhin auch angeschaut, als jemand, der auch gerne ins Fitnessstudio geht, ab und zu nicht so regelmäßig, wie er gerne würde. Bist du ein Gym-Boy? Ich glaube nicht, das, was die da konkrete Doku meinen, bin ich nicht. Nein. Ich nehme auch keine Supplements oder sowas, das ist ja schon alles ziemlich gruselig, was sie da mit 16 alles nicht so reinschieben. Aber weil jetzt, das ist nämlich, glaube ich, worauf es hinausläuft. Wir wünschen uns den luftleeren Matrixraum, wo wir ohne Kleidung da sitzen, ohne Waffen, ohne Sozialstatus die Dinge ausfechten. Wer hat dann noch die Upper Hand? Es ist doch der mit den Muskeln.
Okay, ich würde sagen, der, der Recht hat in der Situation oder wo man das dann auskennt. Nein, der, der besser nackt aussieht. Okay, das heisst du jetzt tatsächlich direkt in den Faustkampf in der Situation? Nee, das ist mir dann auch wieder zu primal. Ich bin schon so Homo Neanderthalensis zumindest, der dann Dinge … Schon Mensch, aber noch nicht ganz angekommen. Genau, der, wo es dann vielleicht schon dann doch um Status geht oder sowas, oder der sieht den muskulöseren Menschen und gibt dann quasi schon direkt auf, weil er keine Lust hat auf den Verlust im Kampf, auf den Gliedverlust im Kampf. Mein Problem in Diskussionen ist oft, dass ich schon mit einem ganzen Rucksack voller Argumente ankomme. Und dadurch wird es oft schwierig, weil die Person... Wie strukturierst du dich? Also zum Beispiel, mein klassisches Beispiel ist Bäckerei und die Leute, also ich finde, es gibt eine klare Richtung, in der man sich in der Bäckerei anstellt, und zwar entlang der Theke und dann weiter, aber nicht im 90-Grad-Winkel zur Theke, weil dann versperrst du den Weg. Das kommt auf Bäckerei, zur Bäckerei, ich habe eine konkrete Bäckerei vor Augen, aber viele Leute stellen sich da im 90-Grad-Winkel an und versperren dann den Leuten im Supermarkt schlicht und einfach den Weg. Und egal wie viele Leute sich an denen vorbeidrängeln, die checken nicht, ah, ich stehe voll im Weg. Die merken das einfach nicht. Spatial Awareness. Und haben keine, so, stehen da, Wut. Und mit denen würde ich gerne reden, aber ich habe wirklich den Rucksack schon voller Argumente und ich glaube, würde ich mit den reden, würde ich mal sagen, okay, ich habe strukturiert. Also, erstens, Alpha, also erstens, die Kasse steht ja hier, das heißt, alle Leute, wenn sie hier stehen, zweitens, der Eingang ist ja da, das heißt, da kommen immer wieder Leute rein, wenn sie da stehen. Drittens, hier sind die Kassen, das heißt, die Leute kommen hier raus und auch denen stehen sie im Weg. Viertens, ich könnte gar nicht meine Wulst an angestauter Argumentationsenergie ankommen. Das kommt nicht an, ich habe zu viel. Jetzt sind wir nämlich in Kommunikationswissenschaft, weil das ist ja so, wie hat Obama dann seine 90 Punkte, bei denen es ihm hauptsächlich ging, im Wahlkampf runtergebrochen? Yes, we can. So. Ja. Ich brauche einen Slogan. Ja, auch eine, die andere mit ins Boot nimmt, die sagt, die so sehr nach Lösung schon klingt und so. Aber das war ja die Idee mit der GO, die Gesellschaftsordner, dass man das institutionalisiert und wirklich dann mit Marken und Stickern und Buttons arbeitet und wirklich sagt, okay, steh nicht im Weg oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Da hat uns ja die Gegenwart auch wieder eingeholt mit dem Anzeigenhauptmeister. Ja. Diese ganz komische Geschichte von diesem jungen Mann, der alles anzeigt. Aber der Anzeigenhauptmeister ist ja Teil des herrschenden Gesetzessystems. Der ist ja voll und ganz Sklave der Verkehrsordnung. Der hat ja keine eigene Idee, sondern der setzt ja nur die geltenden Regeln um. Bei der GO geht es ja darum, neben dem, was natürlich die harte Justiz abfrühstücken muss, irgendwie mit Geldstrafen, eine gesellschaftliche, ja, die Ebene drunter ist es ein bisschen weicher, aber dadurch noch nerviger. So, und dass man daran geht, dass man sagt. Die ungeschriebenen Gesetze. Genau, die ungeschriebenen sozialen, zwischenmenschlichen Gesetze, die keine Geldstrafe erfordern, sondern daran. Wie rechts stehen, links gehen. Sowas zum Beispiel, ja, und das ist eine gute Regel auf jeden Fall. Ja, ja. Aber ja, ich glaube, also ich werde bald Prügel kassieren, ihr werdet das wahrscheinlich mitkriegen hier, wenn ich hier sitze, mit gebrochenem Arm und gebrochener Nase. Weil ich glaube, das würde dich weiterbringen als Menschen. Ich glaube, ja gut, das ist aber ein sehr rudimentäres Männlichkeitsbild, das Gewalt dich stärker macht und charakterlich stärkt, weiss ich nicht. Da haben wir uns jetzt wieder 200 Jahre in die falsche Richtung begeben. Wieso war das jetzt auch nicht gemeint. Ich meine nur, manchmal ist das eine Perspektive, wenn du weisst, dass es die Möglichkeit ist, wirst du vielleicht vorsichtiger. Weißt du, das meine ich nur.
Ja, das kann sein.
Du musst dafür nicht auf die Fresse bekommen.
Aber brauchen wir wirklich mehr Vorsicht in unserer Gesellschaft? Ja, und natürlich auch Verantwortung. Ist ja klar, wir übernehmen Verantwortung. Das Podcast-Ufo ist sich seines Effektes bewusst und deswegen Und da haben wir natürlich gesagt, falls wir etwas anrichten, dann kümmern wir uns natürlich darum, ist ja klar.
Und es geht konkret um Strafzettel, denn es ist ja so, wenn unter, es gibt ja Einfluss, Alkoholeinfluss,
verschiedene Einfluss und wir verstehen uns auch als Einfluss, Existie-Einfluss, Kokain-Einfluss, THC-Einfluss,
Ketamin-Einfluss, schlechter Einfluss, Crystal-M Meth-Einfluss, satanischer Einfluss und eben das Podcast-Ufo.
Und da versuchen wir natürlich immer die Augen und Ohren offen zu halten. Falls wir etwas verschulden, wollen wir natürlich für diese Schuld aufkommen. Und deswegen schreibt Sanja.
Sanja schreibt, ich war vor ein paar Wochen mit zwei Freundinnen in einem Musical, in dem eine weitere gemeinsame Freundin mitgespielt hat. Amateur-Niveau macht er keine Sorgen. Im Auto auf der Rückfahrt haben wir hungrig bei Burger King angehalten und uns in der Schlange darüber unterhalten, wie toll es wäre, auch so gut singen zu können wie die Leute auf der Bühne. Nur Amateur-Niveau macht er. Es ist alles noch wichtig für die, für den Startzettel. So, dann als wir mit dem Whopper auf der Strasse waren, erzählte ich stolz, dass ich ja quasi professionelle Sängerin bin, da ich mal ein Intro beim Podcast-Ufo eingereicht habe und es verwendet wurde, nämlich Folge 337, die das Podcast-Ufo-Sonderfolge Kanalreinigung. Poolnudel. Schockiert musste ich feststellen, dass meine Beifahrerin das das Podcast UFO Podcast Projekt noch gar nicht kannte. Ich wackelte also nicht lange und Schmiss besagte Folge 337 an, gespannt. Moment, wir stehen noch mit Wopper auf der Strasse. Wir sind mit Wopper im Auto. Wir fahren Auto. Wir fahren Auto.
Und Schmiss besagte Folge 337
angespannt, was sie zu meinem
Intro sagen würde.
Ist natürlich ein
in dem Moment ist es unangenehm, finde ich
so dieses. Ja, dann hören wir es uns doch mal an.
So, vor allem, gerade wenn das Intro nur 30
Sekunden lang ist und dann noch eine Stunde Podcast-Folge
kommt und man weiss nicht, wann macht man aus?
Wann soll man ausmachen? Soll man jetzt nicht wirklich durcharbeiten? Finde ich schon mal relativ unangenehm. Aber gut, es war die Scrubs-Melodie. I can't do this all on my own. Das Podcast-Ufo. Und während ich meinen Whopper ass und die Gesichtszüge meiner Freundin beobachtete, die das erste Mal in den Genuss einer Podcast-Ufo-Folge kam, kam es, wie es kommen musste. Ich wurde geblitzt. So, fährt ... Inklusive Whopper im Gesicht, glaube ich. Wir haben kein Bild vorliegen, aber es kann sein, dass Sanja samt Whopper, samt Podcast-Ufo-Genuss, hier geblitzt wurde. So, jetzt kommt unser Jurist, Dr. Stefan Tietze, der das auseinander nimmt. Ist jetzt das Podcast-U von Tietze und Will Legal in Köln. Erstmal, wenn ihr von dieser Datenleck betroffen seid, das könnt ihr hier unten rausfinden, in den Shownotes, in den Shownotes habt ihr den QR-Code. Ich auch. Bist du betroffen?
Das ist irgendwie 20 Euro oder so. Bist du betroffen? Ja, ich bin betroffen. Ich war nicht betroffen. Bei Facebook? Auch nicht betroffen. Ich bin nicht betroffen, genau, wenn ihr betroffen seid, könnt ihr auf WBS Legal mit der Anwaltskanzlei, könnt ihr eure Daten abgeben und im Gegenzug seht ihr, ob ihr betroffen wart von so Hacking-Daten-Lag-Angriffen. Mir ist schon klar, du kannst die juristische Einschätzung machen, ohne Werbung zu machen für irgendwas. Das ist auch möglich. Nee. Was sagt Stefan Tietze, Doktor Anwalt? Stefan Tietze sagt, also, ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig. Zum einen ist weniger der Podcast jetzt Schuld und Thema, als das ihr eingesendete Intro. Sie hätte also auch einfach nur die MP3-Datei ihres Intros abspielen können. War halt in unserem Podcast einfacher zu finden. Sie wollte nicht das Podcast-Ufo zeigen, sie wollte das Intro zeigen. Moment, aber das heisst, du sagst, das Intro ist nicht Teil der regulären Podcast-Folge, wir übernehmen keine Verantwortung für das, was passiert während des Intros? Doch, aber das Podcast-Ufo war Mittel zum Zweck. Es war ein Vehikel, um ihr ein Kram zu zeigen. Aber es ist ja trotzdem Schuldeinfluss, es hat trotzdem Einfluss. Nein. Sie ist ja unter dem Einfluss, sie schreibt ja hier, sie beobachtete, wie die Podcast-Ufo-Folge auf dem Gesicht wahrgenommen wurde. Es geht ja nicht mehr ums Intro, sondern sie hat anscheinend nach dem Intro die Podcast-Ufo-Folge laufen lassen und da kam es zum Blitzmoment.
Angenommen, sie hat auf ihrem Handy die Datei gehabt, podcastufo-intro.mp3, I'm no Superman.
Hätte sie das abgespielt? Ging es um das Podcast-UFO?
Also dann würden wir keine Haftung übernehmen, weil das Intro ausserhalb des Podcast-UFO-Kontexts verwendet werden würde. Geht es um den Podcast oder geht es darum, dieangstalente zu zeigen uns ob wir verantwortung tragen stefan tietze ich frage dich bei ihr ging es bei ihr um den podcast oder ging es darum ihre gesangstalente zu zeigen es ging ursprünglich darum das gesangstalent zu zeigen die podcast ufo folge lief dann weiter sie hat ja gesagt ich wollte gucken wie der podcast bei meiner freundin ankam und dann kam der Blitzer. Das Intro war lediglich der Aufhänger, um überhaupt die Datei zu starten, dann lief sie aber weiter, ungewollt, wahrscheinlich zum Ärger von beiden, zum allen Beteiligten. Die Frage ist jetzt … Nee, genau, und dann ist noch das zweite Problem, was ich habe, Whopper. Ja.
Weil, also, du bist eh schon abgelenkt, weil deine Freundinnen hören gerade dann dich singen und danach auf dem Podcast weiter, du weisst nicht, soll ich jetzt auf Stopp drücken, zeige ich jetzt den Podcast, die kennen den Podcast nicht. Nebenan hast du noch den dicken Whopper in der Hand, wir reden ja jetzt nicht hier von einem kleinen Burger. Nee, nur Whopper. Der Whopper ist gross. Hier heisst es übrigens Plant-Based Whopper, nur am Rande, falls das relevant sein sollte. Habe ich jetzt keine Meinung zu, weil so ein Whopper ist ein ordentliches Geschoss. Er ist ungefähr gleich wie ein normaler Whopper, ja. Gehe ich davon aus. Genau. Geschoss würde ich auch nicht sagen. Es gibt schon... Im Burger King-Sortiment ist der Whopper jetzt nicht der wuchtigste. Nee, aber es ist jetzt auch kein McDonald's Cheeseburger oder so ein kleines Ding. Nee, nee, das nicht. Nee, da ist schon die Hand. Aber kannst du mit einer Hand essen, sag ich mal. Es sitzt kein Döner, es sitzt kein... Ja, aber sollte man denn mit dem Autofahren was mit einer, was essen, was eine Hand aus dem Parkern? Ja, natürlich, ihr willst denn sonst wer mit dem Autofahren essen. Sollte man mit dem Autofahren essen? Als ob du nach dem Drive-Thru nicht irgendwie schon mal in die Tüte greifen würdest, Stefan Tietze.
Du bist fachlich geprüfter Anwalt, aber du musst jetzt hier nicht den Heiligen machen. Du hast vom Vatikan ein Wunder anerkannt bekommen. Eines, das macht dich noch nicht zum Heiligen. Ich bin Sand, Stefan. First, Anwalt, second. Der Vatikan hat dich noch nicht bestätigt. Vatikan. Ein Wunder wurde bestätigt, das zweite noch nicht. So, also, wer sagst du jetzt also wir haben Schuld, sagst du der Whopper hat mehr Schuld am Blitzen als die Podcast-Ufo-Folge?
Ich möchte ein Bild sehen.
Also sie meinte auch hier, ich wollte eigentlich warten, bis der Mahnbescheid hier ist, um euch zu schreiben, aber er ist immer noch nicht da.
Vielleicht habe ich ja Glück.
Lass uns auf den Mahnbescheid warten.
Und dann würdest du sagen, wenn der Whopper gesichtsfeldstörend in ihrem Gesicht bezahlen wir keinen Cent. Genau. Keinen Cent. Also das meine ich, um es mal zu wiederholen, wir zahlen nichts. Gar nichts. Kein Porto, keines Versandkost, gar nichts. Wir zahlen null. Null. Also, Sanja, wir legen das auf Wiedervorlage. Auf Wiedervorlage. Sobald du den Mahnbescheid hast, bitte schick ihn uns und dann können wir schauen, ob der Whopper hier als Komplize mitstraffähig ist oder ob er sich da raushält aus der ganzen Sache. Okay? Gut, alles klar. Abgehakt, abgehakt, abgehakt. So, kommen wir jetzt weiter zu Paul. Paul schreibt, erst mal, Paul beschwert sich, dass wir seinen Namen so oft benutzen in dem Podcast. Cool. So, und es heißt etwas Kontext. Mein Vater hatte am dritten Juli Geburtstag. Dritt? Dritter Juli. So, vermerk das mal. Mein Vater hatte am dritten Juli Geburtstag und er ist mittlerweile stolzer Grossvater und Esel-Fan. Grossvater, ja. Auf Esel-Fan schreibst du nicht auf? Esel-selfen schrieb sofort auf. Okay. Caps. Deswegen haben wir uns dafür entschieden, ihm eine Eselkuschelstunde mit seinem Enkel zu schenken. So, aber jetzt, ich habe hier schon ein paar Fragen. Achtung. Man hört es leider nicht, das ist jetzt reiner Patron-Humor, aber eine Esel-Kuschelstunde mit seinem Enkel. Also wir haben Paul in der Mitte, Geburtstag Vater, Vater drüber, dritter Juli, dritter Juli, dritter Julo, drunter Kind, also Opa, drei Generationen Geschichte, Opa und Enkel, also es ist eine Dreier-Kuschel-Situation, Esel, Opa, Kind, wer kuschelt mit wem? Und Paul nebenan. Paul ist da erstmal raus. Wer kuschelt mit wem? Ja.
Also zu dritt kuscheln ist ohnehin schon schwer, finde ich, weil es gibt immer Ungleichgewichte. Da wir in der Blitzer-Kategorie sind, frage ich mich noch sehr gespannt, was jetzt passiert. So. Deswegen haben wir uns zu entschieden, ihm eine Esel-Kuschelstunde mit seinem seinem Enkel zu schenken. Diese sollte am sechsten Juli stattfinden. Okay, also Geburtstag, dritter Juli. Also ich finde, der Zeitstrahl, der hat sich jetzt relativ klar. Der Zeitstrahl ist absolut felsenfest in sich. Und jetzt bin ich aber in so einem Formatierungsierungsproblem, weil bei 6. Juli macht er jetzt so eine Aufzählung daraus.
Es ist siebtens Eselkuschelstunde. Das ist ja jetzt nicht die Idee. So, also Eselkuschelstunde sollte am 6. Juli stattfinden. Ja. Ich, mein Sohn, meine Mutter und mein Vater sind dementsprechend mit einem Auto unterwegs, zu der oben genannten Esel-Kuschel-Stunde unterwegs gewesen. So weit, so gut, vier Leute in einem Auto. So, da meine Eltern noch recht schüchtern im Podcast-Game sind, ich von eurem Talent aber überzeugt bin, hatte ich mir vorgenommen … Deswegen mag ich die Kategorie nicht, weil ihr immer anderen Leuten den Podcast zeigen müsst. Wie unangenehm! Hatte ich mir vorgenommen … Wie ... Willst du das jemals machen, einen Podcast in der Mark?
Vor allem, das ist unser Podcast-Zylent. Ich hatte mir vorgenommen, Ihnen auf der einstündigen Autofahrt den Podcast zu zeigen. Deswegen hörten wir auf der Hinfahrt erst die UFO-Folge 417, Tüte, und auf der Rückfahrt dann die Folge 418, Lederhut-tragender
Nekromant. Wie ihr euch vielleicht vorstellen könnt, kannte ich zumindest die Folge 418 noch nicht.
Zwischen Ich will das hier gerade hören, Leute, undHört euch das mal an, das ist lustig", scheine ich leider einen stationären Blitzer übersehen zu haben. In Bestensee, Nähe Berlin, also für alle Autofahrer können wir das vielleicht mal durchgeben, in Bestensee, Nähe Berlin gibt es einen Blitzer, Vorsicht, in Bestenseenähe Berlin, beider auf der Hauptstrasse, war leider wegen eines Seniorenzentrums in der Zeit 30er Zone, obwohl es eine Hauptstrasse ist. 30er Zone, obwohl es eine Hauptstrasse ist. So, deswegen wurde ich mit 41 kmh in einer Dreissiger Zone geblitzt. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Ah, sehr spannend, sehr spannend, okay, machen wir weiter. Und muss jetzt leider 50 Euro Strafe zahlen. Vielleicht könnt ihr euch ja dafür erweichen, einen werbungsmachenden Fan der drei weiteren Personen, wir halten fest, Mutter, Vater und sein Kind, also Enkel, keiner von Ihnen in der werberelevanten Zielgruppe, der drei weiteren Personen von eurem Podcast überzeugen wollte, dabei zu unterstützen, diese Strafe zu tilgen. Als Student mit einem Kind und einer schwangeren Frau, Kind kommt in wenigen Tagen, habe ich nicht so viele finanzielle Mittel. Paul, erstmal alles Gute zum Kind, hoffentlich, mittlerweile, das ist ja schon eine Weile her. Ich hoffe, es ist mittlerweile gut angekommen. Es gibt also jetzt mittlerweile hoffentlich einen weiteren Esel-Fan bei euch in der Familie, mit dem man und die Esel gut kuscheln können. Die Frage ist, wie schätzt Doktor Jurtitze das Ganze jetzt ein? Also, zunächst einmal möchte ich sagen, die Aktion geht ja jetzt schon ein paar Monate. Jetzt ist hier eine grosse, eine grosse Betonung war auf dem 3. Juli und dem 6. Juli dem Tatdatum. Das ist ja weit … 3. Juli ist der Geburtstag, 6. Juli war der Esel-Kuschel-Tag. Da, und er hat auch gesagt, er kannte die erste Folge schon, die zweite noch nicht. Heisst, er ist up to date, er kennt diese Rubrik und dann mit dem Wissen dieser Rubrik fährt er Auto. Ja. Also mit dem Wissen, mir kann eh nichts passieren, weil wenn ich den Podcast jetzt hier anmache, er macht ihn sozusagen auch an, sagt, ich will ihn anderen Leuten zeigen. Also er fährt risikobereiter. Das ist die Ab, genau. Du fährst natürlich ganz anders, wenn du weisst, ah, jemand kommt für meinen Blitze auf, gerade wenn ich den Podcast höre, kann ich ihn auch direkt anmachen, von wegen, er verkauft uns jetzt hier als grosse Werbeaktion, nein, das ist eine Absicherung. Selbstschutz, okay. Selbstschutz. Aber machen wir damit nicht unsere eigene Rubrik ein bisschen kaputt? Nein, wir haben damals gesagt, wir zahlen eure Blitzer, wenn wir schuld waren, nicht in alle Ewigkeit sein werden. Moment, okay, also rückwirkend?
Ich habe es so verstanden.
Was? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du merkst schon, dass wir gerade unseren Grab schaufeln.
Stefan, Verantwortung ist doch nicht nur rückwirkend.
Sehe ich nicht recht.
Es geht um die Verantwortung, dass wir aufkommen, falls wir Mittäter sind.
Wir sind ja Komplizen quasi.
Ich würde euch auch davon abraten, Leute da in solcher Leite reinzuziehen.
Vor allem zwei Stunden finde ich schon krass.
Ich bin ein, was ich nicht. quasi. Ich würde euch auch davon abraten, Leute da in solcher Leite reinzuziehen.
Also hin und Rückfahrt. Ich finde, man kann
sagen, ey, die letzten 20 Minuten
machen ich einen Podcast an und ich würde vor allem auch nicht so
ah ja, guckt mal, hört euch den an. Ich würde den einfach
anmachen und wenn Leute sagen, ah, was ist das?
Ah, okay. Aber gut, darum geht's
gar nicht. Die Missionararbeit ist ja eh ausgelagert.
Das ist eh alles Thais. Da müsst ihr euch eh an sie wenden. Klammer auf. Wo bist du, Thais? Meld dich. Klammer zu. Also, was sagst du zu Paul? Ich bin tatsächlich ... Und dann noch ein anderer Punkt. Und da hat er sich ein bisschen verraten. Das kleine Wort, deswegen. Er schreibt, deswegen bin ich 41 gefahren und wurde geblitzt. Er schreibt, deswegen wurde ich mit 41 kmh, passiv. So, davor, vor dem Wort deswegen müsste stehen, ich war abgelenkt von eurem Podcast, deswegen wurde ich geblitzt. Aber was steht da vor? Da wird ein Altersheim gebaut, umgebaut und deswegen ist die Strasse, die er gut kennt, von 50 auf 30 runtergesetzt worden. Also, er hobelt sich selber aus. Er sagt, er wurde geblitzt, weil da gerade gebaut wird eine Baustelle, die er nicht kennt, eine Strasse, die er sonst gerne fährt. 30er Zone, obwohl es eine Hauptstrasse ist. So, wenn du gesagt hättest, gut, ich fahre diese Strasse immer lang, ich weiss, dass da dreissig ist, ich war abgelenkt von eurem Podcast, ich wurde geblitzt, hätte ich das ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken bezahlt. Du sagst aber ganz klar selber, du wurdest gezahlt, weil, du benutzt das Wort deswegen, vorangestellt die Info, da gerade in der Baustelle ist. Es gibt ja hier eine Kausalkette. Man könnte ja sagen, also erstmal guter Case auf jeden Fall, aber ich finde, es gibt eine Kausalkette. Man könnte ja auch sagen, wäre er nicht in dieser Podcast-UFO-Situation gewesen, wäre ihm vielleicht aufgefallen, dass das eine Dreissiger-Zone ist und so schaltet er eher auf Autopilot, weil er so vertieft ist in die neue Folge Podcast-UFO und deswegen achtet er nicht auf Dinge, die vielleicht sich ändern könnten in der Umgebung. Ich würde schon sagen, dass mein Mandant Paul hier tatsächlich unter dem Einfluss stand, der es ihm nicht möglich gemacht hat, auf die neue Situation zu reagieren. Paul ist ein aufmerksamer Autofahrer, der noch nie einen Strafzettel bekommen hat, der sich durch viele verschiedene, das müssen Sie nachprüfen, das müssen Sie beweisen, der sich durch viele verschiedene, sicher kann ich Kram behaupten, der sich durch viele, der sich er sagt nichts, gut, wir haben besprochen, das heisst aber, dass er nicht antwortet.
Er ist mit dem Kopf und sagt, er wurde schon mal geblitzt. Nein, er ist mit seinem Mund formt er, er schürzt, hör auf, Paul. Und deswegen sage ich, er hat sich bisher durch jede auch noch so überraschende Verkehrssituation geschlagen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, hätte er nicht unter dem Podcast-UFO gelitten in dem Moment, der ihm die Sinne benebelt, hätte er das Dreissiger-Schild gesehen und adäquat gebremst. Ich sage, Paul verdient unsere Unterstützung. Wir haben hier einen Fehler gemacht, wir stehen in der Verantwortung, wir haben hier ein, ein, wir haben drei Menschenleben über Paul hinaus in Gefahr gebracht. Vier. Vier insgesamt. Nee, fünf insgesamt. Tatsächlich fünf. Ein ungeborenes Kind, tatsächlich. Fünf Menschen hätten hier elf kmh zu schnell gegen eine Wand fahren können, verunglücken können, und das war mit unsere Schuld. Ach schlimmer, ins Altersheim rein. Was mich ja dann auch, wobei man sagen muss, wäre es schlimmer, also angenommen, du müsstest ausweichen in ein Altersheim oder in einen Kindergarten. Vor dieser Wahl stand Paul zum Glück nicht, aber Paul, jetzt mal nur theoretisch. Genau. Du hast links den Kindergarten, rechts das Altenheim.
Und vor dir dein Sohn. Ungebrochenes Kind. Wen, also und da würden, es würden 50 ältere Menschen sterben, 50 Kinder, von denen aber einer Hitler, zukünftig Hitler sein könnte. Richtig. Könnte. Ja, einer der Senioren ist Gandhi. Also was mich auch dazu bringt zu sagen, wir übernehmen das, Klammer auf, ich hätte gern gesehen, wie viel das dann kostet. 50 Euro. 50 Euro? Ja, 41 kmh in der 30er Zone. Was mich erweicht, ist so ein bisschen das Esel kuscheln.
Ja, das ist auch ein schönes Geschenk.
War es der Hinweg oder der Rückweg?
Das muss der Rückweg gewesen sein, denn wir erinnern uns, die Folge 417 für den Hinweg, die kannte Paul bereits, da kam es nicht zu einem Blitzer, möchte ich auch nochmal anmerken, die Folge 418, die er bei der Rückfahrt gehört hat, kannte er noch nicht, also die Hinfahrt kannte er, Rückfahrt kannte er nicht, deswegen hat er natürlich aufmerksamer zugehört. Was für mich ein klarer Indikator ist, dass dadurch die Aufmerksamkeit eingeschränkt war, weil auf der Hinfahrt ist nichts passiert. Sie sind ja vielleicht sogar den gleichen Weg hingefahren, okay, das ergibt keinen Sinn, und dann ist er da, dreissig gefahren, Rücksicht, ja, er ist ein anderer Weg gefahren. Aber der Rückweg jetzt lässt mich aber daran, jetzt finde ich, ist das Esel kuscheln wieder, kann ihm als Nachteil ausgelegt werden, weil er kann ja noch abgelenkt sein. Jetzt kann man ja sagen, was macht das, da möchte ich auch gerne mal Studien lesen, also was macht das Kuscheln eines Esels mit dir körperlich? So, sehr gut. Gibt es noch einen weiteren Täter, den Esel? Weil Paul stand ja nicht nur unter dem Einfluss der neuen Podcast-UFO-Folge, sondern auch unter einem Esel kuscheln. Serotonin, Dopamin, Oxytocin, Kuschelhormone. Richtig. So, das wird alles ausgeschüttet, weil du mit dem, ich weiß nicht, wie lange wurde dann effektiv gekuschelt mit dem Esel? Das wissen wir nicht, wir wissen nur, wie lange die Hin- und Rückfahrt gedauert hat. Und es war innerhalb eines Tages, alles der 6. Juli. Hol dich das mehr ins Jetzt oder lenke dich das in Zweifel ein bisschen ab, weil du so eine Art Trance bist? Also empfehlen Experten, nach dem Eselkuscheln sofort wieder Auto zu fahren. Das müsste man wissen. Da haben wir jetzt natürlich nicht die Informationen, was das mit dem menschlichen Körper macht. Und wir wissen ja auch nicht, was diese Hormone machen. Kann ja sein, dass mit diesen ganzen Glückshormonen und Zärtlichkeitshormonen man besser Auto fährt als danach. Weiss man ja auch nicht. Kann ja sein, dass das sogar aufgrund der Podcast-UFO-Folge, es hätte noch viel schlimmer sein können, wenn er nicht davor einen Esel gekuschelt hätte oder zumindest dabei zugeschaut hätte, wie sein Vater und sein Sohn mit einem Esel kuscheln. Das hat ja auch einen Effekt, es gibt ja Spiegelneuronen, wenn du dabei zuschaust, wie andere Leute kuscheln, hast das für dich. Das sind alles viele schwierige neuropsychologische Prozesse, die hier alle einfach aufgedröselt werden müssten, bevor wir das sagen können. Man muss ja auch sagen, du fährst ja nicht zu schnell mit deinem Sohn, dem kleinen Sohn, deinen Eltern und deiner schwangeren Frau im Auto. Nein, nein, nein. Du fährst nicht so schnell. Du fährst auch zu schnell mit deinen Jungs, nach einer Dose Red Bull, nach einem Fussballspiel, nach einem Drive-Zu. Nach einem Musical, mit den Mädels, nach einem Wuppe in der Hand. Dann drück man auf die Tube, aber nicht mit Oma und Opa. Ja, genau. Und du bist Student. Das heißt, wenn irgendein Unfall passiert, den du verschuldest, dann verschuldest du dich vielleicht auch sogar finanziell. Also ich glaube, du fährst eher aufmerksam. Naja, es sei denn, es gibt das Sicherheitsnetz-Podcast-UFO. Aber das mal am Rand. Genau, genau, genau. Ja, aber wir sind uns nicht sicher mit dem Esel kuscheln, was das ist. Aber er spricht von einer Esel-Kuschel-Stunde. Das kann jetzt natürlich gemeint sein als Zeiteinheit mit unterschiedlicher Länge. muss nicht notwendigerweise 60 Minuten sein, aber ich glaube, das ist eine, was ist für dich eine gute Kuschellänge? Also ab, wie viel... Mit Eseln habe ich keine Kuschelerfahrung, muss ich jetzt auch offen sagen. Was ist denn das Näheste am Esel, mit dem du je gekuschelt hast? Da erwischst du mich jetzt komplett blank, sorry, weiss ich nicht, was ist eine gute Kuschellänge. Weil wir hatten ja mal Kontakt mit Alpakas. Die würde ich eine Stunde lang kuscheln. Die finde ich auch sehr, sehr kuschelfreudig. Wollen die das? Also das ist ja, ich finde, Kuscheln lebt ja auch davon, ob mein Gegenüber das Kuscheln schön findet. Bei mir zum Beispiel löst sich ja nur Oxytocin, haben das Männer überhaupt Serotonin, Dopamin aus, wenn mein Gegenüber das offensichtlich auch geniesst. Sonst habe ich das Gefühl, das ist eine awkward Situation. Also deswegen weiss ich ja gar nicht, wie lange wollen ein Esel überhaupt kuscheln. Ja, die Frage ist aber, kannst du das bei einem Esel einschätzen? Also könntest du dem Esel es ablesen? Die Augen sagen alles aus. Sorry, aber das ist ja ein Esel, der ist ja hauptberuflicher Kuschelesel. Also kann ja auch sein, dass die wirklich so, scheiße, heute hatte ich, heute hatte ich wieder so eine ganze Rotzfamilie hier, der Opa hat mich angerotzt, das Kind hat mich angerotzt, wirklich, ihr habt keinen Bock mehr, Leute.
Ich mache das noch zwei, drei Wochen und habe mich raus hier. Ich sag's euch, kommt der hier angefahren, irgendwie mit seiner schwangeren Frau, denkt hier irgendwie so ein süsses, kuscheliges und das Kind sabbert mich voll hier die ganze Zeit. Ich bin hier auf herzensesel.de und ich sehe hier Esel kuscheln. Also die Website sagt, du verlierst dich im Alltag, irgendwie wird alles zu viel, du wünschst dir jemanden, der einfach mal zuhört, der für dich da ist, nur dich sieht, dich nicht zu beheben oder verurteilt, dann komm zu uns zum Esel kuscheln. Hier darfst du sein, hier darfst du entspannen, hier darfst du dich fallen lassen.
Es gibt keine Voraussetzung, jeder ist bei uns willkommen. Bei gutem Wetter, also es ist, man riecht nach Keks wahrscheinlich. Oh. Also bei gutem Wetter dürft ihr euch ausschliesslich auf der Weide, draußen auf der Weide niederlassen, auf der Weide stehen rustikale Bänke. Die zum Kuscheln einladen oder ich stelle euch eine Decke zur Verfügung.
Denkt mal, denkt mal kurz, denkt mal ganz kurz bitte, nur auf Spaß, nicht an Esel kuscheln, sondern an Swingerclub.
Denkt nur mal bitte kurz an Swingerclub. Bei gutem Wetter dürft ihr euch draußen auf der Weide niederlassen.
Auf der Weide stehen rustikale Bänke oder ich stelle euch eine Decke zur Verfügung.
Natürlich dürft ihr euch auch ins grüne Gras legen. Es gibt keinen Plan. Diese Zeit gehört euch und den Tieren. Naja, aber ein bisschen mehr euch. Ihr habt dafür gezahlt. Möchtest du ihnen beim Grasen zuschauen, Emma hinter den Ohren kraulen, Frieda putzen, einfach mal die Seele baumeln lassen? Ist es nass und kalt, dann macht ihr euch dem Stall gemütlich mit einer Decke auf dem Strohbund. Wundert euch nur nicht, wenn sich euch, wenn sich dein Platz langsam zur Seite neigt. Die Eselis haben ihn zum Fressen. Och, das sagt doch nicht Eselis. Okay. Erste jetzt nicht, wie lange man kuschelt. Doch, für eine Stunde 35 Euro. Aber können Sie nicht mal zumindest halbwegs einen Nebensatz erwähnen, dass Esel gerne kuscheln oder so? Oder sind es einfach wirklich Söldner, die da abgekuschelt werden den ganzen Tag? Jeder zehnte Termin ist für dich gratis. Buchen wir gleich 20, oder? Auch das Titelbild sieht für mich nach Swingerclub aus, aber …
Oh stimmt, wir haben ein küssendes Paar, das rechts noch den Esel …
Und ein Drink in der Hand hat, so einen Aperol-Spritz, das ist alles ein bisschen …
Das ist ja mittlerweile auch eine riesige Event-Gastronomie, der Esel ist ja mittlerweile weg von seiner religiösen Figur eigentlich als bescheidenes Reittier,
sondern fast hin zu einer Art, ich will nicht sagen Tier …
Prostitution. Es ist ein Cuddle-Worker, kann man auch mal sagen. Also jetzt, ich bin dafür, wir geben 20 Euro dazu. Ich bin dafür, wir geben 7353 Euro. Wir überweisen 7353 Euro. Paul, wir nehmen das auf unsere Schultern. Ich würde sagen 20 Euro. Wir nehmen das auf unsere Schultern. Wenn du jetzt die Rechnung aufmachst, 30 Euro muss der Esel zahlen, 20 Euro zahlen wir, wir übernehmen das voll. Das machen wir aus der UFO-Kasse, nehmen wir das, Paul. Deswegen würde ich sagen, dieser Antrag wurde angenommen. Es ist angenommen. Es macht einfach zu viel Spaß. Ja, falls ihr Schwierigkeiten mit dem Strafvollzugsordnungsamt habt, schickt uns gerne eure Anmerkungen, aber ich glaube, ihr werdet langsam besser, weil ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben am Anfang noch sehr viele Nachrichten, die sich selber komplett ins Knie geschossen haben, mit noch zusätzlichem Ich hab gekifft währenddessen und so. Hier musst du mich mit der Lupe schauen. Hätten dich fast debankt, Paul, aber ich finde es auch gut, dich zu unterstützen. Man merkt nur daran, wie freigeblich du Geld raushaust, auch grosse Summen, dass du nicht Zugriff zu unserem Konto hast. Na klar. Du, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich eine neue Anschaffung. Ich habe lange zusammengewohnt mit Lars-Erik Paulsen und Lars Paulsen ist ein bisschen ein Werbeopfer. Der fällt rein schnell, er ist begeistert, vor allem von Küchengeräten. Und unsere Zusammen-WG-Zeit war geprägt von, ah, ich habe ein neues Küchengerät gekauft, cool. Terminator der Kitchen Terminator, Kitchenator, und ich konnte dann immer langsam dabei zusehen, wie seine Euphorie Stück für Stück auseinandergebröckelt ist, und am Ende … Die Augen werden kleiner, der Blick geht runter, man schrubbt, man schrubbt, die sind so schwer zu waschen, und am Ende war dieses Küchengerät eher ein lästiges Hindernis im Alltag als eine freundliche Hilfe. So zum Beispiel der Nicer Slicer Dicer, da kann man Dinge schneiden. Es ist ein Messergitter, wo man jetzt seine Kartoffel drauflegt und dann haut man oben mit so einer grossen Klappe zu und dann wird das automatisch durch dieses Messer getrieben. Das ist der Nicer Dicer. Slicer Nicer Dicer, ja. Der Slicer Nicer D Ich sag Slicer, Nicer, Dicer, weil es mehr Spaß macht, das zu sagen. Um genau zu bleiben, es gibt ja auch den Nicer Dicer. Es ist der Nicer Dicer. Ich versuche nur, die Werbung zu umschiffen. Und ich musste mir jahrelang anhören, dieser verdammte Nicer Dicer, den kann man nicht richtig gut waschen und man muss die Sachen vorschneiden, die müssen dann klein sein, dann kann ich es ja auch gleich richtig schne. Und ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit viel gekocht, gerne Spaghetti Bolognese, wo du Sellerie und Karotten wirklich super klein schneiden musst und ich habe es gehasst. Ich habe das nicht hingekriegt, so die letzten Stücke und es war alles ungleichmässig und so eine Karotte, wenn man die spaltet, das ist immer ungleichmässig und man rutscht ab und es war nervig. Ich dachte mir jedes Mal, warum denn nicht so ein nicer Dicer? Aber da habe ich wieder an Lars Paulsen gedacht, der mit seinen traurigen Augen da sass. Ich dachte, das müsste mir doch eine Lehre sein. Aber es wollte nicht in meinen Kopf hinein, warum das eine schlechte Idee ist. Weil das ist ja dieses, diese Küchengeräte, die sind ja so überzeugend. Du denkst, das ist ja eine gute Idee. Die sind überzeugend im Pitch, muss man wirklich sagen. Ich habe Lars Paulsen auch dabei miterlebt, wie er versucht hat, den Leister, da ist er loszuwerden.
Er wollte ihn erst verkaufen, er wollte ihn verschenken, aber niemand wollte ihn haben.
Also das Entsorgen war eine ebenso grosse Bürde wie das Haben.
Das ist schon spannend, ne? Also das Produkt ist ja so gross, weil es sich gut verkaufen lässt.
Ja, absolut. In diesen Infomercials. Genau.
Wenn man den erst mal hat, sehr schlecht zu verkaufen.
Aber man hat den schon gekauft. Und dann dachte ich mir irgendwann, ich hole mir den. Nein. Ich hole mir den, obwohl ich wirklich aus erster Hand erfahren habe, wie es ist, den zu haben. Ich habe ihn mir geholt und Stefan, ich bin begeistert. Nein? Ich bin begeistert. Wirklich? Ich liebe ihn. Ich liebe ihn. Ja, man muss die Sachen vorschneiden, aber es ist trotzdem noch schneller, es macht super viel Spaß mit diesem Zonk das reinzuschneiden, es ist alles gleich und klein und gleichmässig und ich muss mir nicht mehr die Finger schneiden, ich muss nicht wieder mit so einer Drittel Zwiebel, wo meine, wo sind die Finger und dann rutscht das alles ab und ist alles glitschig und ich habe richtig Bock und ich kann mir... Aber nicht den Kochspaß mit so einem Plmchen weil das ist nämlich das ding ich habe ich da ich wollte kochen und habe gemerkt kochen ist zu 80 prozent dinge klein schneiden ich dachte ich mache damit der flamme in der pfanne und irgendwie sortieren oder saute und dann schwenke ich das und dann irgendwie wieder mit so einem flammenwerfer die creme brülle ne am Ende schneidest du. Und deswegen, ich bin ein Riesenfan von Nicer Dicer und ich habe ihn jetzt und ich komme nicht umhin, mir vorzustellen, warum nicht grosse Sterneköche das auch nutzen, weil es ist schneller, es ist einfach gleichmässiger und ich würde gerne The Bear nochmal komplett nachgedreht sehen mit dem Nicer Dicer. KitchenAid, Nicer Dicer. Und dieser leidenschaftliche koch der dafür brennt mit seinen tattoos der wirklich die hände verschwielt hat von brennung und dann immer klonk klonk es wäre eine andere serie ein bisschen mit diesem neon grünen ja das hässlichen klumpen das in dieser gritty küche mit den gusseenden Profisachen, aber es ist leichter und ich will den vier Sterne Koch sehen, der nicht sagt, ja, es ist eigentlich schon eine Erleichterung. Nein, nein, ich bin begeistert, aber ich möchte und deswegen möchte ich diese Euphorie jetzt heute hier auch mal einloggen, ihr könnt mir jetzt dabei zuschauen, wie diese Euphorie langsam schwindet. Wahrscheinlich in zwei, drei Wochen, wenn du das Thema nochmal aufbringst, werde ich sagen, na ja, es ist ja in der Reinigung und jetzt vergilbt das ja schnell und jetzt sind die Messer nicht mehr scharf. Lars-Rigz-Pau, du hast auch am Anfang die leuchtenden Augen, die du jetzt gerade hast. Ich bin in der Honeymoon-Face. Wir gucken, ich finde es gut, dass du uns direkt reinholst, weil jetzt können wir am eigenen Subjekt beobachten, wie es nach unten geht. So dass ihr vielleicht entweder von mir lernt oder dass ihr von mir nicht lernt, wie ich nicht von Lars gelernt habe.
Aber das ist schön, dann machen wir jetzt kurz noch die Infomercial-Folge daraus, weil ich bin auch Fan von einem
Der Bucket, Magic Bucket?
Von einem solchen Gerät.
Die Messer?
Nein, dem Scrub Daddy.
Das ist der Schwamm, den gibt es auch, der wurde auch bei Shark Tank vorgestellt, den kennen auch alle, den gibt's auch überall zu kaufen. Scrub Daddy sieht so aus, ist dieser Schwamm. Ah, der Smiley. Genau, der Smiley-Schwamm, der wird ganz hart, wenn man das kalte Wasser dran macht, der wird weich, so einen weichen Schwamm, wenn man warmes Wasser dran macht. Und das ist ein geiles Material, du kriegst alle Oberflächen supergut sauber, brauchst eigentlich nur Wasser immer, und ich bin ein riesen Fan davon, und der löst sich halt, der hat ja dieses unschuldige Grinsen, was aber auch geil ist, weil du kannst dem, damit kannst du auch Messer sauber machen, da hat er auch diesen Schlitz. Steckst du dir das Messer im Mund. Steckst du dir das Messer ins Mund. Oder ins Auge. Ja, dann hast du halt so einen Löffel und dann steckst du sie mal ins Auge und dann kannst du aber die Löffel gut sauber bekommen.
Das ist halt stark. Also es ist ein toll überlegtes Gerät. Oder ins Auge. Ja, dann hast du halt so einen Löffel und dann steckst du sie mal ins Auge und dann kannst du aber die Löffel gut sauber bekommen.
Das ist halt stark. Also es ist ein toll überlegtes Gerät, aber es wurde halt so vermenschlich. Deswegen heißt es Scrub Daddy. Und ich sage immer, hilf mir, hilf mir, Daddy. Und dann, also alles daran ist so. Schrub mich, Daddy. Ey, mach mir die Küche sauber, Daddy. Es gibt auch Scrubmami. Ich mag Scrubmami, keine Vorbehalte oder so, ich mag Scrubmami aber lieber als Scrubdaddy. Okay, warum, was ist der Unterschied da? Scrubmami hat diese harte Seite drunter. Ah, die hat die harte Seite, die so eine Mutter auch braucht, die dann wirklich mal die raue, harte Seite, die dem Kind aber gut tut. Da ist Mami in der Küche und macht die Küche sauber. Zeig mir deine harte Seite, Mami. Und Scrap Mami ist super und jetzt habe ich aber die Idee gehabt, es gibt ja manchmal diese Werbung irgendwie für Depression, Awareness, redet miteinander, diese Public Service Announcements. Und dann liegt jetzt bei mir in der Küche immer dieses grinsende, der grinsende Smiley, aber es ist Öl dran, es fallen schon so Stücke raus, weil ich den immer benutze.
Aber du hast immer dieses grinsende Smiley-Face.
Und da würde ich gerne eine Kooperation zwischen Scrub Daddy und irgendwie so Depressionen.
Und Mental Health Awareness.
Das so, nur Leute, die grinsen, heisst nicht immer, es geht dir gut.
Okay, man sieht von aussen nicht, dass es jemandem eigentlich schlecht geht. Ich will so terrible Bilder, wo Scrub-Daddies und Mommies grinsend irgendwie im Dreck liegen und gepanscht werden von Kindern, Hunden, einmal durchs Öl müssen, durch den Backofen müssen und dann liegen die da rum, sind komplett zerfleddert, aber grinsen noch. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann darunter, ein Grinsen heisst nicht immer, dass es dir gut geht. Okay, okay. Aber du kannst dich auch waschen. Ist natürlich eine interessante Kooperation zwischen zwei Kräften, die man nie möglich gehalten hätte, dass die sich die Hand reichen, aber finde ich gut. Ja. Finde ich richtig gut. Also mal schauen, wenn diese Plakatkampagne die Innenstädte ziert, falls ihr nach draußen guckt, wisst ihr, Stefan Tietze hat hier die Welt ein bisschen besser gemacht. Es gibt auch Dish Daddy. Dish Daddy hat noch so einen Pömpel dran, da kannst du richtig schön die Teller sauber machen. Also ich bin großer Fan, auch großer Fan des Pitches bei Shark Tank damals. Ich glaube, nach wie vor irgendwie die erfolgreichste, erfolgreichste Produkt aller Shark Tank Staffeln der Welt. Aber dieser Daddy-Begriff, der war ja eigentlich eine Zeit lang einfach versaut, so ein bisschen. Aber der ist mittlerweile im normalen Sprachgebrauch. Daddy, Daddy. Das ist einfach so, so Ey Papi oder so. Ey Papi. Ja, genau. Das war schon wieder drin. Jetzt aber ist kein Beispiel für normalen Sprachgebrauch. Ich glaube, da gab es schon noch die Ebene. Aber du hast doch von Raw Dogging erzählt. Ist das nicht auch was Sexuelles? Nee, ich glaub nicht. Aber da bin ich vielleicht auch so naiv und kindlich, wie ich da durchs Internet tapse mit meinen Procs. Ach ja, Raw Dogging used to describe having sex without protection. Ah, guck mal. So, und das, also sexuelle Begriffe werden immer mehr harmlos in das normale Sprachgebrauch eingebracht. Ja, doch, Gegenwartsphänomen. Gegenwartsphänomen, ja. Ich Ich finde es ja zum Beispiel im Englischen immer so überraschend, dieses You suck oder etwas sucks. Das sagen ja auch zum Beispiel Kleinkinder völlig selbstverständlich. I suck. Was ja einfach Blowjob ist, irgendwie. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so wahrgenommen und man hat wahrscheinlich als amerikanisches Kind gar keine Vorstellung, was das Wort überhaupt bedeutet oder warum jetzt saugen, was das soll? Man müsste immer ein Kind fragen, so was heißt das, warum sagst du denn zack? Kinder saugen ja auch, also Säugling ist es also was, ich bin zu klein und unbedarf bei etwas. Als Sack hat das. Weiß ich auch nicht genau. Also verlieren wir die Naughtiness, indem wir viele schmuddelige Begriffe in den allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch einführen, schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare. Und B-Klammer zu, warum müssen es immer englische Begriffe sein, die etwas beschreiben? Warum, weil Raw Dogging, wie der geiler Begriff. Es kommt ja halt aus den USA, ne? Deutschland ist ja hinterher. Wir sind hinterher, das meine ich nur, aber auch mit der Begriffsbildung, also auch etymologisch sind wir hinterher. Ja, absolut. Deswegen, genau, Roh-Hu-Rum-Huren.
Roh-Huren.
Okay, unser Vorschlag, Roh-Huren.
Mal schauen, ob es sich etabliert.
Wir halten mal die...
Roh-Huren.
Doppel H.
Ungünstig.
Wir halten ja vom Laufen, wenn es dabei läuft.
Mal gucken, ob der Duden sich meldet.
Ansonsten habt eine ganz fantastische Woche.
Haut rein, genießt den Sommer.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss. Tschaui, macht's gut.